because I got to the point was facing a
200 year maximum sentence you get 200
year maximum sentence yeah Wow and
similar to your saying with Takashi's
because he got 50 did they're talking 50
you got 200 yeah there's a lot of people
on YouTube right now talking about
Takashi and they have no idea what
they're talking about
even the hip-hop channels they're saying
is his trials gonna be next year in
September he's gonna get at least the
minimum 30 years because that's his
minimum the justice system is completely
Alice in Wonderland those figures mean
nothing what will happen is the
prosecutor over time will plea bargain
with these guys it won't even go to
trial that trial date if it you know
it's probably gonna get moved multiple
times they'll be in court every month
filing motions each side going back and
forth and you don't have to snitch in my
case what we did I met an old-timer
who was doing life and he said look get
a good lawyer and do what's called a
united front so in my case at over 100
people arrested with me only four agreed
to cooperate we had a united front under
Alan Simpson
it was the lawyer that the New Mexican
Mafia had represented and Sammy the
balls case 57 people were arrested
approximately all agreeing to testify
yeah so I think because we had this
united front
hardly anybody snitched it really
frustrated the prosecutor over 26 months
they pulled up every dirty trick in the
book on me there I mean I was at the
point where I was about to kill myself
in the jail it got so rough but at the
end at the end of the day me I was the
head of the crime syndicate wild woman
was number two while Wildman's what
woman out of law real wild man was
number three and none of us got more
than ten years so I thought that was at
the end of the day that was really good
because of the loophole my lawyer got as
a first-time nonviolent drug offender
non-uk US citizen I ended up serving
just under six years just so what would
you're saying is you think some other
things gonna happen with Takashi's
except what will happen with Takashi six
nine right now the prosecutor will have
organized the criminal organization the
crime syndicate in level of importance
so maybe Takashi will be be
under shotty maybe shotty will be a or
maybe will the other way around just cuz
they want to get to cash because he's
the big headline that will enhance their
careers so they will then say to
everybody like effort and K and L
they'll say to FK now look you guys are
small down here you're facing life
sentence is you're all co-conspirators
you all go down for each of us crimes
you guys testify against these guys and
we'll let you do time served that's
generally what they'll say and that's
what they were saying in my case now
they've separated to Kashi six nine
there's all this speculation saying he
snitched already he's gone to prison for
snitches none of that is verified I
think it's far too early probably for
any of these guys to just just just roll
over the prosecutor shot he's obviously
worried about it because in court he's
yelling now don't fall don't bend in
front of the judge which is a really bad
idea that's not a good strategy I had a
situation like that happened in my own
case now if you're forming a united from
how are you gonna get word for the
prison system to your core defense not
to snitch
well they've separated to Kashi so it
looks like you snitch in solve
psychologically that will work bad
against the other co-defendants but you
can get what's called kites these are
letters sent by trustees throughout the
jail system you will send a letter from
Takashi in this prison after that prison
those religious services my guys we had
the whole two back rolls of the
religious services we would all give
each other our hugs and I'd update them
on all the legal news the other thing is
if the cash is in a separate prison when
he goes to court with his co-defendants
they're gonna be in a row of holding
cells right outside of the courtroom
Cates can be passed from cells now
through trustees they think they can
stay tight they can get the word out
that they're doing a united front
so cash she's got the money to get such
a high-priced lawyer to fight back these
low-level guys are thinking right we've
got no money
we've got scum ducks come back public
defenders who just want us to sign plea
bargains
these guys have got the money to get the
high-priced lawyers they're just gonna
let us end up getting you know we're
gonna have no legal representation
but Takashi right now needs to get the
word out we're doing a united front and
paying for a high-priced lawyer I'm not
snitching and hope that everybody stays
tight because once people start to
snitch
then the sentence will go up for the
people who are highest in the
organization so what happens walk us
through you're going to prison how was
that like I mean who who are you what
prison did you go to what level can I
guess a little bit of that's all right
so because I hadn't cooperated
prosecutor they pulled out every dirty
trick in the book so my first year in
the jail I've got this united front
telling everyone not to agree so the
prosecutors like how can we get him away
from his co-defendants let's get him
over to maximum security because all my
co-defendants were in minimum
medium-security now how she did that she
knew I was applying to get my bail
reduced my bail was $750,000 cash only
she sabotaged the bail hearing very
crafty these prosecutors she filed
additional charges and with an
additional seven hundred fifty thousand
dollar bail so the judge not did he not
only reduce my bail he maintained my
original bail accepted the new bail
which made my total bail 1.5 million
when your bail goes over a million you
automatically reclassified to maximum
security autumn so that's the guideline
yeah so that's how I ended up my second
year in maximum security now by the end
of that they tell that's where they're
telling me like like you're going to get
200 years because every time you spoke
about drugs on the foil and carries five
to ten years and this isn't deals this
is just personal small stuff if we go to
trial and lose we could stack that up to
a maximum two hundred year sentence and
they made it clear there was a guy
before me a two-hour to son a dealer he
had a similar case he refused to sign a
plea bargain for fifteen years and they
gave it he went to trial they gave him
two hundred two hundred years 200 every
charge carried ten years maximum and
they stacked all of his charges they did
they didn't run them concurrently they
run them consecutively the justice
system is a business model if you got a
trial it cost the state hundreds of
thousands millions they want everyone to
sign a plea bargain and go over to the
prison system just about down 98% of the
cases go to plea bargain that's it